another confirmation that Stargate is
about to be revived and this time it's
an actor that is saying he knows what's
coming welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV movie channel
[Music]
so there's some information been talked
about by first lieutenant Matthew Scott
well the actor Brian J Smith in an
interview he did online a couple of days
ago with uh sidewalks entertainment
now I'm just gonna play the clip
and then we're going to talk about it no
one's approached you with like the idea
of making another series I don't think
so I know that they're doing another
Stargate like they're kind of Reviving
the franchise a little bit but they want
to do like these you know they're
they're going to do like these huge
these huge movies you know
um and I I have a funny feeling that
they're not going to ask me to be a part
of that
[Laughter]
you never know I mean it wouldn't be so
I mean you're part of the team so I feel
like they do have to
we'll see it's such a you know that
there's so many worlds in that franchise
that that it can go so many different
ways and I I'm curious to see what they
do I'm sorry what was that you know
they're they're gonna do like these huge
these huge movies so if you're a regular
side truck you'll know that before
Christmas I started talking about Amazon
looked like they were going to actually
do a Stargate movie first and we've
talked about how though there was a big
delay basically because Amazon and MGM
didn't actually have a head of film now
around March time they got that head of
film in Courtney Valentini I told you
that not long after that appointment
Jennifer saki sent her a memo a
directorate or whatever you want to say
or drink it to begin development on
Stargate RoboCop I think it gave
permission for Legally Blonde three and
possibly another project that we don't
know quite what that was
and I basically said this was the point
that they finally made their minds up
but because before that they were
dithering over a TV series movie
whatever else personal tenants got from
SGU didn't just say though that they're
going to be doing these movies he said
it was going to be a Revival now that's
the words that we desperately wanted to
hear the most
continuation I would actually say a
Revival is even more than a continuation
really a Revival is bringing a lot of
those other actors back now I said to
you a couple of months ago again first
and exclusively that actually they were
looking at doing a kind of sg1 Revival
bringing some of those actors back but
really having at least an initial
project that would look an awful lot
like and feel a lot like the original
sg1 now it really looks like Brian J
Smith here has done a bit of a Tom
Holland moment and accidentally let the
cat out of the bag because we've been
saying that actually this was going to
be announced as San Diego Comic-Con
deadline to the story just oh gosh six
weeks ago now basically saying that yes
Stargate was one of the projects that
Amazon planned for MGM to return with
and that it was probably going to be a
movie so did Brian misspeak well he said
he knows the Stargate franchise is
returning he he also said these are
going to be big movies now I was told
before Christmas that there were
realistic expectations for these films
but actually that a movie was most
likely simply because one it was what
Jennifer sulky once and she's in charge
but two that Jennifer sulky basically
saw this as an opportunity to create a
Marvel style
um franchise something that would be
movies TV and everything else I mean I
think I spoke about this yesterday when
I talked about the game that's about to
be released to timekeepers in July and
the Amazon consider this to be a
multi-format franchise they want movies
they want TV they want Comics they want
games they really are looking at Star
Wars Marvel for their inspiration on at
very least how to structure the
franchise and what Brian J Smith here is
really talking about is one aspect of
that with returning with big movies now
I said as now as I mentioned a second
ago I was told that they're going to
have realistic expectations so from that
we were expecting budgets in around the
90 million area something that would be
a reasonably big budget movie and it
would be a
relatively low budget movies for say a
Marvel Superhero film but still a decent
budget for a cinematic release
he's talking more about if it's going to
be a big movie I would expect the budget
to be maybe 50 higher than that 120 130
million if we got a budget of something
like that for a Stargate movie now that
would be incredibly exciting so you
heard it here first months ago that we
were going to be getting a Stargate
movie first or very least that was the
rumor that was being knocked around but
how does this affect things like Mark
Fergus and his company penguin and
Parker who we believed and hoped was
going to be taking the reins of this
well it makes me a little nervous in
that I've told you that negotiations
were going on between Mark Fergus and
Amazon Before Christmas
but those negotiations collapsed now
when I hear more news that this is going
to be returning as a series of movies I
think it's less likely Mark Fergus will
be involved the reason for that was one
of the problems Mark Fergus had with
Amazon back then was that they couldn't
make their mind at what they wanted to
do they kept talking about a movie but
he was doing development work on a TV
series Mark Fergus has written scripts
for movies before he wrote the script
for Iron Man so you know he has written
big hit scripts before so it doesn't
necessarily mean he won't be I'm just
wondering if Amazon are actually looking
at a deal with somebody like Warner
Brothers or Sony a big Studio to have a
relationship with while making these
movies because they need to do their
space but also it helps share a bit of
the cost out and one of those Studios
will want to go with a big production
partner that they already work with now
if that's Sony that could still be Mark
Ferguson penguin and Parker because they
are doing other projects together at the
moment
or it could mean that Amazon are
actually planning to go in a completely
different direction now remembering what
Star Trek did with the JJ Abrams ones
they went with whatever time was a
relatively small production company that
only really done TV shows they went with
Bad Robot and Bad Robot then went to
introduce several other big features
could this be penguin in a Parker's
moment to step up
I have heard rumors from different
agents around Hollywood that penguin and
Parker were looking to hire more staff
they were looking for staff writers and
they were looking for all the creative
people so maybe that's the indication
that actually Mark Fergus is in line for
this I just worry that if it's a big
budget movie that they're going to want
somebody a little bit more established
but maybe I'm just being pessimistic so
one more time John what do you know I
know that they're doing another Stargate
like they're kind of Reviving the
franchise a little bit but they want to
do like these you know they're they're
going to do like these huge these huge
movies you know
um so guys comes to tell me what you
think is this as good as a confirmation
for you or is it just one big step
closer
John here could have just been
misspeaking but he doesn't say he thinks
he said he knows and I don't think that
was a slip of the tongue I think he's
done a Tom Holland moment here but what
do you think get into the comments and
tell me if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification so you never miss any of
our new videos or any new big scoops on
Stargate also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and for a
small contribution that really supports
the channel it really helps us out you
get to see them without the adverts as
always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
foreign